comment Kamala Haris cette fille
d'immigré indien et jamaïcain est-elle
devenue la première femme
vice-présidente des États-Unis la
réponse était en partie dans ce
documentaire réalisé par Marjoline grapp
et David Thomson avec désormais cette
question détient-elle désormais tous les
atouts pour gravir la dernière marche et
s'installer derrière le bureau oval de
la Maison Blanche nous allons en
débattre maintenant sur ce plateau de
débat dooc en compagnie de mes invités
en commençant par vous an dessine
bienvenue vous êtes professeur émérite à
l'université
parinanire juriste et américaniste et
votre dernier ouvrage s'intitule les
États-Unis et la démocratie publié chez
l'armatan à vos côté Laor Kenton
bienvenue à vous vous êtes maître de
conférence en civilisation des pays
anglophones à l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin et chroniqueur au magazine
Rolling Stone votre dernier livre c'est
pas tout à fait le dernier livre
d'ailleurs il date un tout petit peu
s'intitule atlas historique des
États-Unis et il est publié aux éditions
Autrement puis enfin avec nous Laurence
SIM bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
ancienne correspondante notamment du
groupe Canal Plus et de l'agence ka à
Washington et c'était entre
1992 et 2017 quelque part dans ce film à
nos confrère américains nous rappelit
que 15 vice-présidents 15
vice-présidents sont devenus
président des États-Unis la question que
tout le monde se pose après avoir vu ce
film cette carrière fulgurante cette
histoire comme les aiment les Américains
hein finalement concernant Cala Haris
peut lui permettre d'avoir tous les
atouts pour devenir à son tour président
des États-Unis en tout cas elle se
prépare je pense qu'en France elle est
sous-estimée on l'a vu dans le
documentaire c'est une femme qui a une
carrière absolument incroyable qui sait
se battre qui peut être très émouvante
on vient de le voir et qui sait ce que
tomber et se relever veut dire dire et
moi ce que j'aime bien en camala Haris
c'est cette détermination et c'est je
reste dans l'ombre je suis derrière et
comme on ne la voit pas on dit elle est
nulle elle est beaucoup moins nulle que
ce qu'on pense c'est une femme politique
redoutable mais elle aura un petit
problème est-ce que les démocrates dans
le moment sensible où on est aux
États-Unis la laisseront passer est-ce
qu'elle correspond à la vedette
démocrate qu'il va falloir pour battre
le républicain qui sera nominé bientôt
personne ne sait on verra elle se
prépare elle aura à affronter le peuple
américain mais elle aura aussi à
affronter l'establishement démocrate et
c'est ça qui va être intéressant est-ce
qu'elle peut passer au cas où Joe Biden
ne se présente pas au cas où Joe Biden
est empêché physiquement et cetera de se
présenter est-ce que le Parti démocrate
la laissera à être la candidate du parti
ça je ne sais pas alors oui elle a
beaucoup d'atout effectivement elle est
intelligence et sa carrière est
incroyable et elle sait faire campagne
elle a fait campagne pour être procureur
ur de San Francisco ensuite Attorney
General ministre de la Justice ensuite
sénatrice elle sait parler aux foules et
les foules sont en lièe elle a à la fois
les atouts qui sont ses handicaps ces
atouts elle est brillante c'est la
première femme la première femme noire
et cetera mais ce sont ses handicap
parce qu'il faut voir que dans les deux
hypothèses en fait que que Laurence
disait c'est-à-dire est-ce qu'elle va
être un atout en tant que candidate
vice-présidente de Biden ou bien toute
seule que ce soit en 24 ou en 28 h
toutes ces éléments sont passés au
rouleau compresseur de la sphère
républicaine de désinformation Fox News
les réseaux sociaux et durant ces 3 ans
de vice-présidente dès lors qu'elle
bougeait le petit doigt c'était
immédiatement une critique pour dire
qu'elle avait été nulle sur
l'immigration nul sur ceci et surtout
pour lui dire que comme Biden elle était
socialiste et communiste donc il va
falloir qu'elle se batte certes un peu
contre les démocrates qui sont pas tous
enthousiastes mais aussi contre contre
cette désinformation et rappelons que
aux États-Unis ça se joue dans 4 ou 5
états pivots à 10000 voix 20000 voix
l'Arizona c'était 10000 la Pennsylvanie
c'était 25000 et cetera donc c'est très
très juste juste pour revenir un instant
hein sur ce qu'on a vu dans ce
documentaire carrière fulgurante certes
elle a gagné toutes les élections à
laquelle elle s'est présenté jusque en
janvier 2019 elle se déclare alors
candidate à la présidence dans le cadre
de la la primaire des démocrate qu'elle
ou elle se retira au profit de de Joe
Biden finalement qu'est-ce qu'elle a
apporté dans le ticket Biden Kamala
Harris qu'est-ce qu'a apporté Kamala
Harris à Joe Biden dans l'élection Joe
Biden pour qu'on comprenne bien alors
Joe Biden c'était engagé à mettre à côté
de lui homme blanc d'un certain âge
quelqu'un qui soit un petit peu le
contraire une femme si possible pas
blanche et nettement plus jeune parce
qu'il y avait cette question de la de la
survie et du remplacement elle cochait
un peu toutes les cases on rappelle que
Biden a 80 ans aujourd'hui camala Harris
en a 59 ouais elle vient elle les a eu
il y a pas très longtemps donc il y a
quand même une différence d'une
génération il se pose moins la question
de l'âge avancé et il y a un certain
nombre de de signaux sur le progressisme
il fallait que ce soit une femme si
possible non blanche et cetera pour
montrer que les démocrates n'avaient pas
encore élu un homme blanc d'un certain
âge contre un homme blanc d'un certain
âge qui était Bernie Sanders et cétait
un petit peu ce qu'on leur reprochait au
niveau de la base parce qui a aussi
cette dimension là alors le problème
c'est que le champ des possibles était
quand même relativement restreint il y
avait un certain nombre de possibilité
mais elle était probablement la plus
éminente et la plus évidente elle reste
dans ce champ des hommes non enfin des
non hommes non blancs non âgés la plus
connue la plus éminente parce qu'elle a
été sénatrice elle été vice-présidente
elle est capable de lever des fonds
probablement plus que les autres et
surtout elle a ce qu'on appelle aux
États-Unis name recognition c'estàd que
tout le monde la connaît y compris ceux
qui ne l'aiment pas moi je voudrais
ajouter quelque chose je pense qu'elle
est déjà en campagne et qu'on ne le voit
pas en France et c'est ça qui me frappe
par exemple au moment des élections des
mis de terme c'est-à-dire au moment où
il y a eu en novembre dernier cette
majorité qu'il fallait déterminer tout
le monde disait ah ça va être terrible
le Congrès va devenir républicain et
cetera et en fait les démocrates ont
comme disent les Américains limité la
casse pourquoi parce que mal Haris a été
faire une campagne absolument incroyable
loin des caméras sur les universités
pour essayer d'avoir le votes jeune et
surtout sur les femmes elle s'est battu
sur cette sur ce combat de l'avortement
qui est tellement important pour les
Américains et maintenant quand vous
regardez très précis après la la
décision de la Cour suprême américaine
l'IVG n'est plus un droit fédéral aux
États-Unis aujourd'hui et elle s'est
battu là-dessus pour que les femmes
continuent à avoir le droit d'avorter et
maintenant elle est sur une autre
bataille qui touche touche énormément
les Américains et là aussi elle le fait
dans l'ombre c'est-à-dire la bataille de
la législation de la vente des armes à
feu et quand on connaît la société
américaine et qu'on voit à quel point
les Américains sont touchés par cette
violence quotidienne des armes à feu
dans les écoles Cala Haris elle va
là-dessus elle reçoit la Maison Blanche
les gens qui comptent qui ensuite
retournent dans les états que vous avez
cité qui disent ah j'ai vu camala elle
est vraiment motivée donc elle fait un
travail de fond qu' va falloir
surveiller très rapidement je voudrais
dire que moi je pense que si c'est pas
cette fois-ci ce sera jamais et là je
suis un peu en désaccord avec vous parce
que le Parti démocrate a des stars dans
les starting blocks qui attendent qui se
disent bon pour nous ce sera pas 2024
mais ce sera la campagne de
2027-228 et je pense que si elle y
arrive pas cette fois-ci ça m'étonnerait
que là le Parti démocrate la laisse
passer pour revenir en 2027- 2028 et je
pense notamment euh à cet homme qui déjà
est en campagne pour 2027 enfin en tout
cas l'élection de 2028 avec la campagne
de 2027 qui s'appelle Gavin Newsom qui
est le gouverneur de Californie et je
suis absolument certaine que Newson ne
veut absolument pas laisser passer Cala
Harris devant lui pour 2027- 2028 donc
c'est où maintenant ou jamais pour elle
à mon sens alors je veux bien rebondir
sur les deux points oui elle est très
très bonne alors est-ce que c'est dans
l'ombre pas tellement mais là en
septembre elle a fait le tour de je
crois une douzaine
d'universités et elle va porter le
message de reproductive enfin le droit à
l'avortement le droit de vote les LGBT
enfin toutes les choses qui sont
susceptibles de mobiliser les jeunes et
les étudiants et ça s'appelait le combat
des libertés qui un truc incroyable
comme slogan politique voilà et donc on
a on a peu parler mais donc oui elle est
peut-être consciente que c'est sa chance
moi Gavin newsum je n'y crois pas trop
parce que c'est le gouverneur de
Californie il est très très bon il se
met en tandem ou en opposition avec le
gouverneur de Floride parce que plus
différent c'est impossible leur
politique leur personnalité et cetera
mais c'est un homme blanc de l'état d'un
état libéral donc comme tout se joue
dans les états pivots il faut quand même
voir que souvent les démocrates ont
besoin de choisir un candidat qui vient
plutôt du Sud cela étant camela est
aussi californienne quoi qu'il en soit
bah le début des des des primaires du
côté démocrate et pour bientôt hein ça
commencera comme d'habitude du côté du
du côté de la la Caroline du Sud et
c'est prévu pour le 3 février prochain
donc qu'on est on est tout proche et
puis Joe Biden est déjà he candidat il
l'a annoncé c'était le le 25 avril donc
qui briguerait un un 2 mandat euh bon
dans ce cas de figure on peut considérer
que camala Harris ça va vraiment être
marathon momen hein la femme marathon
c'est pas elle qui va faire la campagne
de Joe Biden parce que euh à l'âge qu'à
Joe Biden il ne pourra sans doute pas
assumer les déplacements nécessaire he
pour une campagne américaine et et dieu
sais si si c'est considérable en terme
de de kilométrage de bon bon c'est elle
qui va faire la campagne de Joe Biden
pour beaucoup sur le terrain c'est comme
ça que les choses risquent de se passer
compte tenu de cette déclaration de
candidature de Joe Biton pour un second
mandat c'est possible ça dépend aussi de
l'agenda quand on a un agenda
international qui est aussi volatile que
ce que l'on voit depuis plusieurs
semaines et plus largement plusieurs
mois avec l'affaire ukrainienne et puis
dieu sait ce qui peut sortir encore dans
les semaines à venir on peut aussi
imaginer une répartition des rôles avec
un président qui est au charbon malgré
son âge on a vu qu'il pouvait encaisser
des des voyages internationaux à haut
risque haut des beautés donc bah il est
annoncé comme c'estil mais il est encore
capable de faire le job et pendant ce
temps-là répartition des rôles entre
président et vice-président elle
pourrait très légitimement assumer cette
campagne là sur place en plus des
dossiers qui lui
reviennentou on va les rappeler hein ces
dossier depuis le début de cette
vice-présidence peut-être hein
l'immigration bien sûr à la frontière
mexicaine ce qui est pas un cadeau non
ce qui est pas un cadeau mais de toute
façon le vice-président se retrouve
toujours avec tous les vice-présidents
se retrouvent toujours avec un certain
nombre de dossiers qui sont des dossiers
épineux et donc qui ne font pas leur
affaire pour une campagne une campagne à
venir donc ça c'est vraiment toujours le
problème de ce job qui n'est pas
forcément qui est un tremplin sans être
un trempin il y avait les armes à feu
vous l'avez évoqué à Laurence tout à
l'heure notamment hein et puis il y a eu
laaprès George Floyd hein qu'elle a eu à
à gérer c'est c'est c'est une Amérique
extrêmement divisée on est un an avant
l'éle présidentielle on est dans un an
ce sera l'élection il va se passer plein
de choses moi je pense que aujourd'hui
les thèmes électoraux c'est la violence
dans les écoles les armes à feu
l'intégration
l'immigrationou et les inégalités
économiques parce que jamais cette
société n'a aussi n'a autant été divisée
sur l'inégalité économique et il y a une
radicalisation qui se fait et donc
camala Haris elle a par rapport à ça en
étant une femme en étant issue des
minorités en étant quelqu'un qui se
mobilise contre l'avortement elle a sa
carte à jouer sur la politique
intérieure qui préoccupe tant les
Américains mais je pense que par rapport
à d'autres ça va quand même ça risque
d'être un peu compliqué pour elle je
vous donne la parole tout de suite
simplement tout à l'heure vous nous avez
dit c'est maintenant ou jamais hein
finalement sur cette échéance de 2024
moi simplement pour que les gens qui
nous regardent comprennent bien Joe
Biden s'est déclaré candidat euh de fait
c'est lui qui sera en première ligne euh
comment peut-elle avoir accès au au à ce
fameux bureau oval de la Maison Blanche
ça voudrait dire un scénar on n'est pas
là pour faire de la Politi fiction mais
quand même ça voudrait dire que Joe
Biden serait réélu et que durant ce
second mandat d'une manière ou d'une
autre ça serait Camal Haris qui
prendrait la suite alors encore une fois
il faut bien expliquer ce qui se passe
si jamais Joe Biden qui est âgé et qui
pour le moment surtout sur la séquence
internationale qu'on est en train de
vivre vient de faire une prestation
extraordinaire les républicains et les
dém démocrates ont adoré la manière dont
en PER sage en grand per sage Joe Biden
s'est comporté en allant en Israël si
jamais il arrive quelque chose à Joe
Biden il n'y a pas d'élection
présidentielle anticipée il y a le
vice-président qui vient et qui termine
le mandat commencé donc imaginons que
Joe Biden soit réélu en novembre
prochain et on lui souhaite évidemment
pas on va pas faire de la politique
fiction mais en décembre il a un malaise
il n'est plus capable de gouverner à ce
moment-là son vice président devient
automatiquement automatiquement
président et c'est très le scénario que
pourrait avoir en tête Joe Biden par
exemp moi je pense pas du tout parce que
il est pour le moment Joe Biden il veut
la y aller puis on verra encore ce que
le Parti démocrate décide en coulisse il
y a des tractations qui se passent c'est
un parti démocrate extrêmement divisé
qui parfois est opposé à Joe Biden qui
considère trop vieux il commence à le
dire il y a plein de gens qui attendent
moi je pense que encore une fois camala
Haris doit lutter aussi contre ces
ambitieux du parti démocrate qui se
disent à un moment donné elle faudra la
mettre sur le côté pour prendre sa place
vous souhaitiez réagir non simplement
ajouter un thème de campagne qui est la
démocratie non pas parce que c'est une
de mes préoccupations mais quand même
Joe Biden en parle fréquemment et c'est
vrai que ce qui va se jouer en 2024
c'est un basculement ou non de des
États-Unis dans un régime illibéral il y
avait un article dans le New York Times
qui montrait dans un régime pardon
illibéral enfin d'une démocrature ce ne
sera plus une démocratie c'est-à-dire
que si Trump bah donc une dictature oui
redevenez avec des élections mais qui
vont toujours dans le même sens là vous
vous êtes dans vous dans le scénario où
par exemple Donald Trump pourrait voilà
être élu par ex oui mais c'est une
possibilité qu'il faut vraiment évoquer
pas sousestimer le trumpisme de manière
politique c'est pas un clown en ce
moment Donald Trump et le trumpisme est
devenu un mouvement extrêmement
important qui a beaucoup changé depuis 4
ans avec une base extrêmement radicale
et effectivement qui menace aussi la
Constitution américaine VO et des
niilistes au Congrès on l'a vu avec le
feuilleton des speakers donc l'idée
c'est que et le président Biden et camel
Haris font campagne sur ce thème de la
démocratie à l'intérieur et à
l'extérieur et cela ça mobilise pas mal
de gens elle en parle dans son tour des
universités à chaque fois qu'elle le
peut et il faut pas sous-estimer cela
car la prise de conscience des attaques
que les républicains font subir au droit
de vote dans les états où ils ont la
majorité il faut en sorte de supprimer
des bureaux de vote de supprimer des
jours de vote anticipés de procéder à
des radiations non justifiées donc
quelque part il y a un vrai danger et
ceci ça mobilise les électeurs alors pas
nécessairement pour Kamala je suis
d'accord mais pour le Parti démocrate il
faut pas oublier Queaux États-Unis comme
ailleurs on vote pas forcément pour on
vote beaucoup contre et donc on essaie
de mobiliser Arve aussi en France ça
arrive un peu partout en réalité hein
mais aux États-Unis ça un nom negative
partisanship c'est-à-dire queon n'est
pas démocrate parce qu'on est démocrate
on est démocrate parce qu'on a peur des
républicains et inversement on a peur
des communistes démocrates donc Cala
Haris et d'autres essaent de faire en
sorte que les gens votent pour elle ou
pour son camp pour empêcher justement un
basculement qu'on peut voir émerger avec
un nouveau speaker qui était très pro
Trump mais pas seulement très pro Trump
très faut expliquer ce que c'est que le
speaker c'est le nouveau speaker de la
chambreés est le président de
l'asseméetion
peut avoir qui peut avoir un rôle dans
la détermination d'une élection très
serrée et donc le problème c'est
que en 2021 quand il y a eu toute c tout
ce litige sur l'élection de de Biden ù
les trumpist disaient que Trump avait
gagné en fait on a eu des républicains
qui ont joué le jeu de la Constitution
en disant en fait non c'est vraiment
Biden qui a gagné on ne sait pas si on
aura cette fois-ci des républicains qui
joueront le jeu mais ce que je voudrais
dire c'est on na jamais connu les
États-Unis dans une crise parlementaire
telle que cette ce pays traverse euh
cette crise vous avez une crise
politique sans précédent vous avez les
institutions même américaines qui sont
menacé alors tout le monde en France dit
ah mais regardez Trump il est comme si
ah mais regardez il est comme ça c'est
terrible est-ce qu'il va aller en prison
par c'est pas les c'est pas les bonnes
questions là qu'il faut dire les
questions qu'il faut se poser c'est
est-ce que la démocratie américaine est
menacée et je pense que tout le monde a
en tête quand
même l'assaut du capital peut-être du
capit du capital c'est un traumatisme
politique pour les Américains un
véritable traumatisme et ce qui va se
jouer sur l'élection présidentielle qui
vient c'est est-ce que les américains
choisissent une démocratie ou quelque
chose d'autre dont on ne connaît pas le
nom parce que il faut lire ce que Donald
Trump le nom a été évoqué à l'instant
hein ce côté là de la table c'est ils
annoncent tout ce qu'ils vont faire ils
nommeront des juges qui seront à leur
solde ils nommeront des shérifs qui
seront pour eux qui mettront beaucoup
plus de sécurité dans certaines villes
sensibles ils annoncent des politiciens
extrêmement dur et ceteraiste voilà et
donc on voit en ce moment se construire
sous nos yeux un modèle qui plaît à la
moitié de l'Amérique et camala Haris
là-dessus si elle décide de faire
campagne la campagne sera extrêmement
beaucoup plus violente qu'avant avec une
menace physique à mon sens pour chaque
candidat démocrate qui s'opposera au
trumpist tout ce que vous venez de nous
dire l'une et l'autre d'ailleurs sur les
menaces concernant cette fameuse
démocratie
américaine ne va peut-être pas dans le
sens de d'un atout majeur du côté de
Cala Haris peut-être que est-ce pour
cela que les Américains lui préférerit
un homme comme Joe Biden malgré son âge
mais en se disant avec son expérience
avec son son vécu lui peut au moins
faire face au défis auquel doit faire
face aujourd'hui les États-Unis non oui
si ce n'est que la question ne se pose
pas aujourd'hui en ces terme Joe Biden
est candidat donc c'est dans quelle
mesure camela Harris en tant que
candidate à la vice-présidente peut-elle
l'aider à mettre en lumière ces
différents dangers cette défense des
libertés afin de convaincre les
indépendants parce que ça ça va se jouer
là il y a ceux qui sont pro Trump on les
fera pas changer il y a un certain
nombre de démocrates qu'on ne fera pas
changer et donc ça va se jouer comme
d'habitude à la marge mais l'Amérique
est une société optimiste et quand vous
parlez aux gens très rapidement il y a
toujours ce côté nous allons donner
aussi une leçon au monde et peut-être
que en étant optimiste de manière
américaine on peut dire que en ce moment
cette société américaine montrera
qu'elle a envie de calme qu'elle a plus
envie des tempêtes politiques qu'elle a
plus envie des cris perpétuels qu'elle a
plus envie de cette radicalisation et
Joe Biden là dans la séquence
internationale qu'on traverse très
sensible montre que finalement en tant
que président calme il parvient à faire
depuis quelques semaines une unité
autour de ah nous avons besoin d'un peu
de calme et c'est peut-être ça la notre
d'espoir en ce moment le problème c'est
que la plupart du temps sauf exception
en 2004 par exemple les élections ne se
jouent pas sur l'international et dans
les panels mes collègues qui sont en
relation internationales généralement le
déplore ça se joue sur l'économie et la
perception de l'économie et c'est ça qui
est la tragédie des des politiques de
Biden et de Harris actuellement c'est
que il communique beaucoup sur des
résultats économiques qui sont bons
l'inflation baisse les salaires montent
le chômage descent enfin tout semble
aller dans le bon sens il y a pas la
crise économique la récession qu'on
annoncé donc tout va dans le bon sens
perception des Américains l'économie
s'enfonce donc comment on fait quand on
est président et vice-président on peut
communiquer on fait de la pédagogie
comme on dit en France mais il y a une
une résistance de l'opinion sur la
perception de l'économie et les
indépendants qui sont la clé de
l'élection le grand drame c'est que ce
sont les électeurs les moins bien
informés et les moins intéressés par la
politique donc en fait ce sur quoi ils
forment lors décision c'est une
information assez inégale assez inexacte
des perceptions assez lâches et donc le
problème c'est que comment on fait pour
atteindre ces gens-là avec la vérité de
la situation économique sur l'économie
là je suis un tout petit peu pour la
première fois en désaccord avec vous
parce que je pense qu'il y a une
popérisation des classes moyennes comme
jamais et que lorsque vous parlez au aux
Américains lorsque vous allez aux
États-Unis que vous voyez à quel point
en ce moment par exemple les crédits
immobil sont à plus de 7 % c'est ça ça a
jamais été depuis 20 ans aussi haut la
classe moyenne dit on travaille mais on
a plus d'argent le niveau d'endettement
est absolument incroyable et ça pour les
démocrates comme pour les républain CL
moyen qui vote habituellement démocrate
qui une classe moyenne qui vote
démocrate ou qui peut justement se être
classé dans les indépendants par moment
il vote républicain par moment il vote
démocrate mais l'argument économique
cette peur de la récession c'est ce qui
revient
svent déement a beaucoup surf làdessus
il nous reste 2 minutes on va revenir
sur camala Haris Cala Haris elle est à
l'aile gauche du parti démocrate
aujourd'hui c'est pas une femme seule
j'imagine il a il y a du monde derrière
elle qui sont ceux qui soutiennent Cala
Haris dans le combat qui qui est devant
elle c'est bien le problème elle est un
peu seule ah on ne sait pas où elle se
situe elle est plutôt modérée elle n'est
à l'aile gauche donc elle va être jugée
comme trop timide par l'aile gauche du
parti démocrate et comme trop autre
chose et c'est vrai qu'elle je j'ai
toujours du mal à penser pourquoi elle
ne suscite pas l'adhésion quelle est la
part de la désinformation républicaine
parce que quand même Fox News et les
autres ont tapé sur elle
considérablement et quelle est la part
que parce qu'elle a sa campagne
lorsqu'elle s'est portée candidate à la
présidence n'a pas été bonne elle a
arrêté très très vite avec un chiffre
elle était 1 % des électeurs donc est-ce
que là c'est un autre type de plafond de
vert elle a été très bonne dans toutes
ces autres campagnes est-ce que là elle
ne réussit pas à franchir le pas je ne
sais pas il y aura un plafond de vert
pour camala Harris mais ce ce qu'on
espérait dans son camp c'est que elle
soit la candidate noire même si elle
n'est pas que noire qui allait susciter
l'enthousiasme de la communauté noire
qui est une grosse partie de la
coalition démocrate et on a remarqué
qu'en fait c'était pas du tout le cas
les Noirs ont voté Biden le vieil homme
blanc bizarrement et donc ça
correspondait pas au cas
théorique qu'on espérait et donc bah là
elle a pas véritablement cette cette
forme de clientèle espéré et donc ça ne
prend pas donc si on comprend bien si
Biden y était pas allé pour un second
mandat et si elle avait décidé d'y aller
al aurit peut-être peu de chance de
représenter les démocrates alors en ce
moment ça serait une campagne compliquée
parce que il y aurait moi je suis
persuadée qu' aura une énorme rivalité
démocrate et que ce serait vous savez la
série House of Cards où tout le monde se
tue derrière et ETA là ce serait house
of camala il y aura des gens dans le
parti démocrate qui diront elle n'est
pas la candidate assez porteuse pour
passer face à Trump si Trump parvient à
avoir la nomination et ce que je trouve
très intéressant c'est qu'on est
finalement tous les trois d'accord sur
quelque chose elle est très seule et ça
quand vous êtes une femme politique êt
très seule quand c'est difficile à mon
sens c'est compliqué B on finira
là-dessus un grand merci vraiment hein à
tous les trois d'être venu sur ce
plateau de débadoc après ce ce
documentaire consacré à à Cala Haris on
verra ce que nous dit l'avenir hein
concernant l'avenir de cette première
vice-présidente des euh des États-Unis
aujourd'hui vos réactions ça sera sur
hashtag desbadoc Sarah eelier m'a aidé à
préparer cette émission aujourd'hui je
l'en remercie euh prochain rendez-vous
avec dbadog bien ce sera tout simplement
bien sûr avec son documentaire et son
débat à très
[Musique]
bientôt